hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to man of Madyan I
would like to point out something I'm
apparently 24 percent of the way through
this game and I'm not a hundred percent
sure what that means but it seems like
I'm twenty four percent of the way
through this game so who knows maybe
there's a lot more features to be
enjoyed about the game from the
multiplayer aspects of it maybe I have
to visit that but for now all I know is
the single-player aspect so that's what
I'm gonna be doing alright back on the
boat eh I know that we're gonna have
some problems with those fishermen so
we're like 10 seconds out of the jaws of
certain death well certain I mean that's
relative in this meatball meatball this
meatball pulls a ring out of God knows
where yeah where did you hide the ring a
lady never tells
Oh needless to say this lady was
impressed well play there man no wasn't
coming back didn't get us some more
beers after he helped Fliss maybe he
decided hey I'll drink some and then he
got drunk and since he was drunk he
forgot to bring it to us and he just
kept on drinking and he drank all of it
sounds like you've had some experience
with this kind of phenomenon yeah I've
been studying it for you I'll go look
for him wait it's not a big boot in the
plane huh I left it below deck if you
want to check it out okay so how does it
feel to soon be known as be mrs. Julia
Smith
it does have a nice ring to it honestly
I wasn't sure how it would feel but now
that I hear it it does have a nice ring
yeah there we go
now you're speaking my language I'm
taking lessons I can't wait for us to
plan everything together I was so
worried you might say no of course I was
gonna say yes you do more you Thomas the
second you said yes I could see our
whole future rolling out ahead of us I
could see some futures too uh playful
adoring playful like a rug so you can
walk all over me whatever go I'll go
find them what you just relax wait a
minute what oh hi found one other or
flip no way it cuts what let's go get
him sure what which one is you know
where the magic happens what on behalf
of my family I'd like to apologize for
my brother acting like a horny fifth
grader I it's okay I can deal with
children Conrad beers where are they oh
yeah the beers I'll just get them now
what is happening I'm so confused
I'm so so confused oh there's the
brother
oh wait that's the brother and wait oh
never mind
wait wait no you're right I was wrong
but everybody's here let's take a look
at the navigator since my dad or me
maybe we can figure out why the plane
was out here where'd you put it
it's in your case okay I'll go get it
Hey
oh okay so how's it feel to be a man
post proposal uh-huh okay nice nice nice
nice bro bro bro bro bro bro over over
the top I hate everyone on this boat
until I jump off okay hey almost time
for barbecuing got the pad yeah sorry I
got distracted noise let's go let's go
up I come here vixen I Oh easy tiger we
should get back
you'll get no resistance there okay
alright everyone check it out what from
what sure Ingold what who wants to find
some sunken treasure so what do you
think hmmm
coordinates those are coordinates
alright maybe the planes destination you
think we could get there by tomorrow it
takes a couple hours if the weather
stays steady wow you find anything else
there was a flight plan on board that
seemed to indicate it was a rescue plane
yeah that makes sense
after the war they turned long-range
bombers into rescue plans and then this
Wayne must have been shot down cuz it
was riddled with bullet holes I found
one lodged in the fuselage huh and it
was full of life rafts and stuff gotten
shot down before they could deliver all
the raft there was only one missing
reckless all of you excuse me I told you
to leave everything down there alone oh
come on we've been through this already
I'm not talking about the law no hey
they were respectful no you did whatever
you wanted whatever you took it was too
much what what you're right we should
have been more careful That's not me I'm
sorry what we're doing okay maybe I
don't know you where did this should
have never gone down to that claim in
the first place it's bad luck you think
you can scavenge down there and it makes
no difference but every single thing you
bring back has an essence it's like a
ghost you invite to the surface there we
go
huh I never thought about it like that
you never think about much of anything
well maybe I never heard about such cool
ghost stories they're not cool ghost
stories not like for fun people drown in
these waters and you have to respect
their resting place damn straight
Fred you got a fun ghost story right
yeah I heard a story happened right
around here - let's hear it we could all
use a good show let's hear it I bet you
can spin a good yarn it's kind of messed
up actually scare away a little bro ok
here goes this story is true it had
happened - right near here in an old
lighthouse classic setup wait
true story where'd you hear this ah well
down by the dockside I found an ancient
old man skin like a leather book
eyepatch wooden leg the whole nine yards
and for a dollar he told me his secrets
Souza logit the lighthouse stood atop an
atoll isolated from the rest of the
world of lone beacon in the night a
sailor's respite the lighthouse keeper
would hear the waves pounding the rocky
shore one misty morning he comes upon a
woman covered in blood she's stumbling
down the beach he hurries to her aid and
she falls into his arms sobbing as he
hurries her back to the lighthouse he
asks where she's from he doesn't waste
any time
smooth hush the woman answers I live
here the lighthouse that's the skin
you're upstairs right now twist of
course the lighthouse keeper says that
isn't so of course he's a live there
alone for years and the woman becomes
hysterical and it's just her parents are
upstairs so they go to the top of the
lighthouse and they're just lay down on
the floor it's a man and a woman
brutally murdered with an axe always an
axe I mean do people even use X's
anymore I'm just reporting the facts
cliches an all chopped up those little
tiny giblets have an axe so gross okay
so who did it so the woman she's still
hysterical says her husband did it and
he's still here in the closet huh the
husband a so is this a warning 12 future
brides hey no backsies
you're locked in so the lighthouse
keeper creeps over to the closet opens
the door
and sure enough there's a man inside but
he's cut his own throat
horrified he looks closer to see the
dead man's face in the dark closer
closer and he sees it's his own face and
then it's eyes bulge out and screams
super twist nice
no one's gonna question about his whole
face nice one Squire doing the thing you
have me going
who's gonna say about household face my
broad oK you've all had your fun nice I
can do that on demand that'd be pretty
cool no no no cuz according to standard
vessel regulation we're all required one
more beer before anything may issue
regulatory institutional protocol
subdivision 1099 uh-huh where'd you read
that the Internet oh so you found a
website that tells you to drink beer
under every circumstance I'm just
following orders man yeah bro bro bro
over and out
bro bro no one's gonna comment about
that thing but does happen though you
know how his face went off and then he
was fine apparently and also per weird
outburst at the random no and how I
didn't get to actually do anything I was
trying to poop the whoops didn't book
okay all right cool good great glad
all right you think that people would
lock doors E if I was on a boat I'd
still lock my doors I'm gonna be ready
just in case I have to do something here
I'm ready
okay so I that was all pointless oh okay
good great
okay this is
this is a weird change of pace
hmm
[Music]
uh.okay
guess I was closer to you so that makes
sense
Hey
[Music]
I'm more than a little confused more
than a little confused but okay sure
yeah what whatever
whatever it's all good okay I think so
all right there you got a little got a
little something on your head
[Music]
almost free oh look that cut on her leg
oops I guess I should have reacted
better even though I didn't know that I
was supposed to do anything hey so uh
good news bad news bad news I don't see
how this could get any worse
bad news is these are kind of maybe the
fishermen I pissed off earlier oh god
damn it
Conrad great just great and the good
news I recognized how was that good news
I thought you were gonna ask the good
news first there's such an idiot Jesus
sucks were they gonna do to us don't
worry didn't really kill us they would
have done it already
not just worried about being killed all
right um I think untying people we got
to get untied like now that seems like a
smart move
all right nobody knows they're out here
little lady you already know me enough
now let's make the most of it you can go
[ __ ] yourself you piece of [ __ ]
you're the little lady
I didn't dodge that one
um you know treat later sure yeah let's
go out like a douche oh yeah you know
how to treat a lady right
slow down
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm gonna tell you
okay finish read it later where why I'm
so confused
none of this is making any sense I don't
get it it's giving the arbitrary choices
just to make a choice but they don't
actually mean anything if you already
feel man what was even the poetry me
what was even at the point of bringing
me upstairs there was no point no point
to bring Conrad upstairs there was no
point nothing happened
they didn't have a reason to bring me up
and now I'm back exactly where I was
what was the point of that oh Jesus it's
just a little bit of ear that's no
problem why alright well being untied
deep stick shut the [ __ ] up I don't
think they're gonna hit her they have an
influence for sure seems to be getting
buddy-buddy with him
she's my brother yeah he's hiding he's
okay
all right Tara
this is the most this is the most
bizarre kidnapping I've ever seen in my
life did you leave it this is like if we
could take a lesser prize there's like
some kind of an improv scene because
they say they got kidnapped okay yeah
what was the point of bringing her out
no reason ah [ __ ] [ __ ] this makes no
sense Julia tell me what happened they
asked about our parents
what how much money they have I'm sorry
what does it took my ring Julia it's
okay it's okay
now we just have to wait and see what
they want to do with us yeah yeah okay
all right yeah that
eight seconds
storms eight miles away we came here on
a boat maybe we can take it yeah yeah
it's a speedboat
I mean guy he's got a gun well at least
one of us can get on their boat get some
help
uh if you can distract them I can get on
that boat the dude with a gun won't even
realize until I'm long gone seven
seconds I can get out through the window
we gotta break these off first did you
loud they'll hear it we're gonna break
on during the Thunder good call I'll go
through the window and get the boat you
guys distract them Conrad just stay
focused and get to the boat okay let's
do it this is really weird two three
four five six
I click see
what the hell are you thinking what guys
know
what I click what I click what are you
[ __ ] kidding me are you kidding me
but I I quit what
[Music]
don't [ __ ] yourself what
oh I didn't know okay I are you really
kidding me with this buster
[Music]
it's amateur hour over here bliss I got
this let me handle it
I swear what are you doing you idiot
careful don't make this worse think
about what you're doing boy boat just
get to the boat let's keep trying to
give me orders
ah
escape that's what the thing said to do
right
god I hate I hate that I don't I don't
know the buttons as they are I seriously
I don't dig this use it if you have to
are you are you [ __ ] Sanders or this
[ __ ] I don't know
WSB as WASD I know it up down left and
right
sit no I hate people deco similar to
stop Fela who's to me okay
[Music]
I was so mad I'm so mad I'm so mad Olsen
come here
I'm so which one of you is going to tell
me about this Manchurian goo I'm so I'm
so upset I am so mad I'm so very upset
about that that is so infuriating li
stupid that's like you don't understand
how dumb that is cuz that's really dumb
that's what I call real dumb alright
whatever
it's it is what it is like I could do
anything else about it at this point
oh man you should have escaped when you
had the chance
look madam I get I tried shut the [ __ ]
up there's no harm in just talking you
want to talk
[Music]
keep the volume down I'm just gonna say
it bliss has gotta be in on this she
these guys they travel in the same
waters she's the captain and they barely
laid a hand on her
I bet you told them about the Manchurian
goal they're in cahoots how dare you are
you out of your mind how did you come up
with this [ __ ] how [ __ ] dare you
you over privilege [ __ ] you're all in
this together this is a trap and you set
it down
so put a cork in it
sit still oh yeah come with me
find out the longest um is gonna laugh
you try anything anything fishy
and maybe consequence
Duke of Milan requesting weather update
over
we read you everything okay
ah
we have been kidnapped
was a brilliant idea
you [ __ ] won't get away with
this the police is gonna hunt you down
dream on motions of me please leave it
to Deborah Baraka and GPS
I don't know it as
well thanks for the save I guess but
that don't you
okay yeah just cut it all
I
thanks I guess what happened
and you will know about Brad's hiding
somewhere Brad is under the bunk bed
yeah just shout that what what we can't
leave him down there
growl
we need to get a bottle bigger he's not
safe right buddy come out what
oh there is I'm sure there was a point
to that I'm sure there's a point to all
of this any sense none of this makes any
sense at first it was charming notes
completely nonsense cold wonder how they
get up
why aren't they corralling them donk all
right sure yeah that's a thing
yeah
I know they're trying to shows that
corpse in the lifeboat is when that
soldier fell down in the last everyone's
still alive things could have been quite
different I don't know how man I don't
know how kind hearted creature I am I'd
like to offer you some forewarning of
what's to come
tempted forewarned is forearmed okay we
were barred at Venice act 2 scene 7 the
Prince of Morocco pulls a scroll from
the eye of a scull and reads all that
glisters is not gold often have you
heard that too anyway now that you've
reached a point of significant distress
I presume you're eager to get back to
your story but here's a thing everything
may not be entirely as it seems
[Music]
probably shouldn't have said that
thanks man of Madonn thank you that
makes total sense by EM so flabbergasted
right now
the part because I mean just it's just
so weirdly made like I'm not lying about
this this game is just weirdly put
together
alright see ya buddy so you're just
gonna leave five prisoners with two
people watching them standard numbers
say that okay what is that
go
Oh you Konrad's go with it
just from the sense of if I was a
kidnapper if I was this guy this makes
no sense for what this guy is doing why
new Jesus why are they wall walking
together buddy-buddy like no one's
threatening anybody here nope no thanks
oh yeah the body and the lifeboat that
would have fallen out long ago oh I'm
playing now you can see how I would not
assume that because of the way that the
game has been for the past forever okay
I'm over here doing de gouges there we
go hmm yeah oh okay
you sir are you you you you you ha ha
you you listen I'll just whisper in your
oh don't you walk away from me sir
listen I'm just gonna tuck right into
your ear you sir are in Assam I will be
with you in a hot second but you my
friend you're an [ __ ]
an [ __ ] that's what you are yeah I
don't care
here take some cash right on your face
that's all right and looking this way
now hey Brad by the way how have you
been where have you been man how is that
hiding under that bunk was a good good
great good great that's great ok
my bracelet I think good thing they cut
you that's a problem Brad had that same
trick Oh am i playing now I feel like
the person that was in charge of this
game has never made a game before making
my hair stick up so far it's gonna jump
on my neck uh-huh
do I dare look death in the eye all
looking at it right now buddy the person
who is in charge of making this game has
no idea how games work because like
until dawn was a very like cinematic
experience and there wasn't like tons
that you were interacting with but this
one is majority not play and it's not
even close in in like play to not play
it's not close thanks buddy thanks and I
don't know if it's gonna change really
don't know okay anyway I'm Anna okay
pause real quick because what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna step back I'm gonna take
off my cynicism hat and I'm gonna put it
right over here right there sorry let me
take off my [ __ ] detector right out
of my brain and place this over here oh
I'm gonna take out my sarcasm module and
I'll put it right over here oh and I'm
gonna take out my [ __ ]
enhancer it's down here it's like to
enhance my [ __ ]
Emma just throw it away and I'm gonna
remove all of my preconceived notions
directly through my chest hey there we
go okay pasta and I'm gonna go into this
with all my criticisms gone all of my my
cynicism 'he's gone all of my I'm not
gonna be a negative Nancy anymore gone
I'm gonna go into this with fresh eyes
it's a new experience I'm gonna stop
[ __ ] on it and I'm
to treat this seriously and I'm gonna
try to win this turn objective follow
the kidnappers okay I can do that
lead on alright I'll lead on then going
to go scuse me that didn't mean to brush
up so close to you alright I'm going to
go buddy going to go am I going this way
I don't remember what to ask you Oh rad
alright good now the game's just trying
to jump scare you I don't know why like
I don't understand I mean until dawn had
some chief jump scares but I don't know
what this is trying to do to private
O'Neal you're recovering Patterson's
guard duties tomorrow he is sick again
conveniently it's always when he has
guard duties in hold 3a first is 2400
check the chart for rotation William P
Ford copy to UM
AMS wait no that sergeant Ralph Baker
wait it's not William p4 that's Ralph
Baker things are not always as they seem
I'm seeing the docs I'm connecting them
it's all a lie again there's the third
time this week
none of us will like down here maybe
Patterson should just block up just get
on with it
RB Ralph Baker not William P Ford that's
right okay cool I'll take that bug never
know when I'm gonna need a note from the
1940s this way all right hey how's it
going everybody everyone wait for me
good okay
thanks man okay well son good talk you
see
okay
okay I mean it still is 5b three even if
they got a gun I think we could
overpower him okay
did that shadow just make her grow a
mustache block in here this black hey
thanks fool we didn't need it we got a
lantern and you got a lighter awfully
convenient okay who needed a light man
these this kidnapper sure are nice oh
that's right she got clocked in the nose
cuz she she called for a rescue that's
right okay hold that thought real quick
because I want to see what this is all
going speed boat okay Alex took the bang
stick Julia used the bang stick
Alex's knife was not used in the dive
Conrad rushed for the speedboat during
the kidnapping
Conrad TAC tuner during the kidnapping
Conrad failed in his escape to the boob
on a successfully overpowered junior
with a knife which had been taken on the
dive and he brought Alex on the deck
with a knife of the throat Connor didn't
fall for Olson offering him the gun okay
but Conrad's here Brad told Alex the
Falls god I was proposed to Julia Julia
said yes to only announced it irrigated
with two others talking about later they
were both happy fisherman took Julie's
the bends
Julia waited to decompress before surfer
and saying okay what wait what those
meatheads seemed spooked even those
meatheads boot
you think this ship is the material gold
we are in the vicinity of those
coordinates we can't just sit around
need a plan yeah we're not exactly in
the best position to be making any moves
second they let their guard down we got
to take advantage of it and get off the
ship yeah man this whole rust buckets
one tetanus shot from the bottom of the
ocean we already tried to escape didn't
exactly work out they swiped our
distributor cap gonna be difficult to
get anywhere without it thank you okay
what exactly is a distributor cap now
pretend you're talking to someone who
doesn't know anything about boats well
typically a distributor cap is designed
to distribute voltage from the coil to
the correct rotor which in turn it's an
essential part of the engine what I'm
not taking her anywhere
what a nerd those guys are out panning
for Manchurian Goldner do they think
they're gonna find in this floating
coffin we gotta take advantage and look
around for a way out of here okay you
split up pliss I just wanted to say that
I might have gotten things kind of wrong
back there excuse me I may have kind of
prematurely come to the conclusion that
maybe you know you're working some kind
of side deal with these guys or whatever
but I I mean obviously that's not true
they're being just as bad to you as they
are to us oh yeah allow me to translate
he's saying that he's sorry oh I gave it
I gave your apology as kind of accept it
cool cool cool cool all right
hey cool cool Hey look it's all good
hey I'm not mad anymore because
apparently everything worked out well
I'm not sure why but they did okay
thanks for getting that cheer out of my
way yeah I'm gonna look at this reasons
probably goes ship by those reasons
reasons yeah you do a nice perch I don't
know what kind ship with you got him
baby doll I miss you like crazy three
months until my next leave and jumping
you through your arms three months I've
been on some shore leave with the guys
had a few beers but this is a drunk text
from the 1940s don't worry I'm keeping
everything ready for you if you catch my
drift
I'm talking about my pain Oh of work I
hope that posture yours is leaving you
alone I know that you can take care of
yourself but I feel helpless being so
far away and I wanted to keep you safe
Cincinnati Kentucky wait hang on
Cincinnati Kentucky okay as a man from
Cincinnati Ohio I've never heard of
Cincinnati Kentucky but I do they didn't
know that some of Cincinnati kind of
spills out into Kentucky but it's called
Covington but I've never heard of
Crescent springs Cincinnati Kentucky and
I don't think at any point since Anna it
was part of Kentucky and especially not
in the 1940s I'm you know actually I
don't know maybe I'm wrong Hado wrong
I was only raised in Cincinnati Ohio so
what would I know I get a lot of time to
think while I'm guarding the cargo hold
it's dark and spooky down there some of
the other guys have seen a figure
roaming around but I've always got you
with me to keep me safe to Oslo I'm dead
I will be with you soon as a ghost and
get his job as a mechanic and then we
get married and have babies we'll be
happy together forever except that I'm
dead love you so much Miller X hope you
don't mind me reading that note right
next to you Julia pushing today mrs.
Smith hey where were you man okay now
I'm not talking to you talking to these
glasses real creepy their glasses why
would they be that creepy
alright cool good uh-huh I don't know if
I feel you I don't know if I feel
anything I'm kind of Numb inside all
right well I want to look at that all
right okay I don't need to mash no
buttons for this one oh would you look
at that of edit Hey look right down over
here what I found
why
[ __ ] give me a minute gonna see if I can
give it off yeah you do whatever you
need man do you need any help do you
need help with that take a look I'm
looking right where I am do you need do
you need me to come over there oh you
need me okay I'll be right back hey you
take care now what's this
this newspaper I can't seem to read it
weird Oh Coast gangland killing of 1947
archeologist missing in Iraq 24 British
archaeologists have gone missing in the
Zagros Mountains of Iraq the Hodgson
expedition arrived in the kingdom in
September last year with the stated goal
of unearthing the ball right I don't
know wow I can't believe they get
current newspapers on a boat how you
doing Lewis
are you done talking okay I guess I'm
done listening then okay well I'm just
gonna back off here a little bit and
maybe go back to that vent well I do
love vents hey how you doing Flynn say
could see alright later you like my
earring got a new piercing pretty cool
luck I can't get it on Ben
no now you got there in the first place
we're all gonna look I guess that's what
we really are gonna look no we're a bit
like this would go just find out I think
we just gotta find out maybe there are
law oh yeah sure
big man on campus someone should create
a distraction
this is gonna be loud lightning okay
Conrad you do it
okay I'm gonna bang bang on the door Oh
distract Hey okay what's up hey hey yeah
you Long John Silver and [ __ ] but what
are you guys doing out there Pieces of
Eight me shiver me timbers you
one-legged [ __ ] yeah it's farming
permits yeah
let's do I'm warning you I am an
American citizen you really want
president yeah you guys come with you
each and every one of you personally
you hear me I'm talking to you
[Music]
well that worked out nicely
okay well I'll replace that probably
smart hey there we go
he was already surprised before he got
in the door like dude no they can't be
gone I can't believe it
they outsmarted me Oh am i playing now
no I'm not nothing
I'm not playing at all neither are you
but you know that's a different that's a
different thing the Conrad just do this
to the camera done what the I've loved
what they've done with places around
here I swear they just did the first
take on all of these like everything was
just a first take run and then nothing
else but I mind if I explore a little
bit dude I love paper especially a blank
paper
wait it's not blank which way I turn it
Wow extra guard duty regulations due to
the special security precautions on this
mission additional procedures must be
adopted by soldiers on guard duty double
guard duty on all doors and all watches
no talking no playing of games no
smoking no alcohol no gambling and
definitely no games not on this game no
way Guard personnel found breaking the
fourth wall of any of these regulations
will be met with the stern as the
punishments up to and including playing
a game by order of Captain Ford guys
nobody's allowed into 3a seriously
nobody come on that's where all the
games are you can't do that now here I
won't allow it
anyway good talking to you I guess I
should finish this letter I've run out
of paper Hey look everybody go hey guys
come on this is not funny guys come on
no I don't mind me just gonna keep
exploring I hope there's more notes from
the past
laundry Oh Just My Size there's the
mystery the smelling socks a bunch of
briefs
all right you always talk to yourself
man man that was good to look at I'm
glad I did that anything else all right
cool
that didn't get me I was just faking it
that was a fake nice fake uh here's the
mystery of the pungent pants and the
sweaty shirts oh I guess this is done
there's nothing okay good
there's nothing here is there there's
nothing here okay goodbye I'm glad I
went in this room I'm glad they made
this room I'm glad they spent resources
to make that room anyway I'm off then no
more secrets to get I guess no no no
what in the holy hell you want to you
want to run that by me again and leave
all their stuff behind okay I'll walk
through that door you want to run that
by tell me you sorry right you guys saw
that right
okay I take back everything I've been
criticized in this game about that was
one of the most well executed spooks
[Music]
I think the game is now hitting its
stride I think all of that was just one
long warm-up sequence leading to this
one if it can keep that up oh I swear
this game might actually be pretty
competent in the spook Department I'm
not joking
if you guys don't know what I'm talking
about rewind the video and check out
that moment just as I watched you walk
through that doorway and look in the
right side of the frame cuz uh
oh hi hey how you doin sis cuz you might
want to yeah of course oh well alright
you I was done with that thought all
right that's all I had to say about that
I think I've made my point okay well now
I'm on it oh yeah cool Alex yeah I just
stand there all creepy-like and not
moving that's that's real good yeah
thanks okay bye Alex I wonder what would
happen if Conrad actually made it off if
I was actually able to do the quick time
events properly I don't know hello can I
not get that please there we go
ah old chewing gum perfect oh no it's
just a rat skull why did I pick this up
I have no idea that's on my hands now
uh bye Journal I'm not sure I like the
hesitation before anything happens hello
you gonna open it up okay why did I need
to be even bother with that the
skipper's Kayode the booze for this
whole game damn trip there's nothing
like being sober to make you realize
just how quiet took ship is there was a
fight between these dumb Schmucks Wilson
and Anderson right after we sailed but
Ferris nipped that in the bud real quick
and it's been quiet as a church ever
since I got talking with the fella to
help load up the ship he told me they
put about two coffins onboard which
isn't so weird maybe we are soldiers
after all but he said it was some guy
make sure the coffins were all put in
one of the holes just right real precise
not the treeman you get if you were any
old grun
I mean Incan who could it be in those
boxes Friday 13 what an ominous day to
make a journal entry booze was still BOM
lost but Perez said he felt drunk after
four cups but I said he was talking
baloney don't even know how to spell the
word but he was talking it who was like
ditch water Horace said they got a mate
smooch some supplies they lifted meeting
up later on 6:00 to check it out
Saturday 14 what an ominous day to write
a journal entry this heard one of the
guys knuckle look at those boxes gonna
find him and see what he saw so there
was his skulls on him all weird we're
lightening the rods I don't know what I
was all about maybe you can even help me
get into walk let's all set
who reckons you could stick me in
tonight I look forward to journal entry
number 15 what an ominous day oh there's
more
nevermind Sunday 15 it's all off the guy
who's gonna help me get in the hole -
signed off sick doc Finley said he's
some kind of flake which might be true
but Miller says it's something else man
that guy makes good beer something weird
about that place
mail is kind of a butcher but god damn
the good booze wouldn't want to be
causing a pinch with him that's you're
sure Tuesday the 17th the most ominous
day of all Perez said that the boys made
more hooch who bummed out to sneak and
try some for Elsa down at oh no / new
batch worse than the last one never
listen to names damn fool idea from
Perez ever again never even going to
Paris either I don't like the French
Saturday you're 21 last night I was on
duty with Wolowitz can never pronounce
his name right and goddamn if he didn't
quit me out he got spooked and started
babbling about some sergeant they called
Jones to win em I ain't the jungle I
even haven't even been to no jungle
wrecking the Joneses his crew was just
opening up the box he's travelling home
like uh saps I sneaked a look in Jesus
there it was just like the guy in the
poet said all laid out real nice Old
Glory over each one if it's Jones in
there they've done and proud good old
Uncle Sam wouldn't lead any SS out there
he makes sure we all come
Uncle Sam wouldn't leave us high to
drive oh good old Uncle Sam always
making sure we all come wait wait no I
think I got the wrong guy wanted to go
for no go Uncle Sam making sure we all
come alright ok good good that's the
best journal I look forward to entry 22
I think I've gone mad and I think also
I'm have time for this episode
yeah I'm unsure about the way this game
is going but I am into it I'm committed
to the end I've made some mistakes but I
will live in my grave mostly because I
don't think of WASD as WASD I think of
them as up down left and right so if you
ask me to hit W on command it's not
gonna work out so good for me but their
c'est la vie as the French would say so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you're thinking of this
stuff in the comments below it's it's
fun it is kind of fun I am enjoying
myself very much I have a lot of issues
with how the game is constructed it
doesn't seem to be anywhere near as
elegant as until Don was alright so
thank you again and as always I'll see
you in
bye-bye
[Music]